microa are one type of gal cell in the
brain which are derived from the
mesodermal
lineage and they are kind of like the
resident immune cells in the brain
microa are not born in the brain which
is pretty different from other two gal
cell types like astrocytes or
oligodendrocytes microa are of
mesodermal origin and they derived from
the Primitive myoid progenitors present
in the Yol Sac during embryonic
development they develop from the
mesodermal lineage and eventually they
populate the Brain before and even after
the
birth so this is a timeline of micral
development or the development of all
the gal cell type one can see the micral
innervation happens in the brain pretty
early at around uh the gestational week
5 to 30 this is the timeline when the
micro cells inate the brain so microglia
has plethora of function one of the key
function is to eliminate damaged neurons
also they take part in synaptic pruning
release they release Ross and many other
proteases which can have effect in the
overall brain function they release cyto
kind which might be involved in
neuroinflammation they recruit oligo
dendro progenitors and another other
cells which can model the neuronal
circuitry they promote repair and
regeneration as
well they can phagocytose debris and
other foreign materials which are
present in the cell so that is why they
are resident macrofagos in the brain and
overall they can scan and Survey the
cellular environment for any kind of
pathogen or pathogen Associated
molecular patterns now let's look at the
function in bit more details microglia
are d dynamic in terms of morphology
they retract and extend their processes
all the time and this is a highly
Dynamic process microglia are like
security guards they constantly S search
and monitor the local environment
looking for potential
Intruders so they can engulf cellular
debris like these ones also they can
engulf damage end of a
neuron they can do this kind of function
because they have path they have pattern
recognition receptors which can
recognize damage Associated molecular
pattern or the pathogen Associated
molecular
patterns now microa play instrumental
role in pruning of the synapse so you
can see here the microglia are closely
associated with the synapse and help in
this pruning procedure micral activation
due to the brain injury or infection is
really important in terms of f brain
functionality because when there is an
injury microa which are in resting state
gets
activated these activated microglia are
very different they are bushy and they
contains less processes also they can
secrete potential cyto kindes which are
pro-inflammatory in the nature now
question comes how does microglia
recognize the injury site once activated
microglia can also interact with other
cell types such as t- cells and even
stimulate them to produce more
cytokines so microglia can actually
locate a injury site via specific
signaling molecule such as ATP injury
sites secretes
ATP and it's kind of like a danger
signal that is scanned by the microglia
with the help of purinergic receptor
present on them and thereby they can
locate the injury site and quickly
migrate to that
location now microglia is quite diverse
in terms of their nature so recent
single cell RNA sequencing drive has
found out that within the brain there
are different classes of microglia each
has slightly different function so each
of these types are based on their
morphology the molecules they express on
their surface or the cyto kindes that
they
secrete depends on specific disease
context so microa is highly associated
with many neurod degenerative disease
one of the most common one is
Alzheimer's
disease many Alzheimer's risk genes are
highly enriched in
microglia such as trim 2 msa4 Etc so
this allows the scientist to believe
that microglia is the dry f for disease
progression this kind of point of view
is still debatable but it's an
interesting
Angle now it turns out that in
Alzheimer's disease there are plues
which are actually uh surveyed by microa
which triggers the microa to release the
specific pro-inflammatory cyto kindes so
these microglia are known as disease
Associated microglia this is a specific
state of the microglia
so the signals that are secreted from
disease Associated microclear triggers
asroy activity and they make the aryes
more reactive then reactive astrocytes
further form specific chemicals that can
damage the neurons potentially leading
to neuro degeneration and this is the
Vicious Cycle that happens in many neuro
degenerative disorders including
Alzheimer's so this disease Associated
microglia is a recent discovery and it
turns out that disease Associated
microclear are forming in the
Alzheimer's brain by two step procedure
one the down regulation of micral
checkpoint genes and second the
upregulation of phagocytotic and lipid
metabolism
genes but still it is debatable that
what is the important role of these type
of microa is it beneficial or
detrimental for Alzheimer's brain so
scientists are still struggling to find
an answer for that however in this video
we can understand how microa is super
important in context of
neuroinflammation so I hope this video
helps get more notes and flash card in
our Facebook page or Instagram page you
can see all the links in our description
you can support our Channel using super
thanks you can contribute using PTM
PayPal or
UPI see you next
time